sur le rivage les enfants jouent avec
les premières neiges dans le petit havre
de pêche depuis wernick touques
les débardeurs du camilla desgagnés
s'affairent à débarquer la marchandise
ont des charges aussi le même manière
qu'on des charges dans les places en
afrique où il pleut pas dans les années
20 30
[Musique]
ça se pratique n'a plus nulle part au
monde
[Musique]
on amène des barges le déchargement avec
nos petits remorqueurs on met ça là
dessus on va des chars le sens où la
plage
c'est des conditions assez difficiles
vous travaillez transporté quoi faire
nommé le sur un bateau jamais vu la
luzerne ne transportez quoi je serais
pour qu'une idée les meubles ikea
beaucoup de nourriture c'est faux
on a des containers réfrigérés c'est la
ligne de vie
[Musique]
l'équipage sera au large du village
quelques jours
il travaillera sans relâche de l'aube à
la nuit
c'est un paquet qui tombe l'équipage est
désolé comme ça car elle sape si calme
où d'importants besoins
michel duplain est venu pour la première
fois dans le nord alors qu'il était un
tout jeune matelot
quarante ans plus tard c'est lui le
capitaine du camilla desgagnés
photographe amateur il ne se lasse pas
de cette région du québec que justement
si peu de québécois connaissent au début
parce que c'est une terre de guéret
voulant bible à cause que cing la roche
blanche
d'ailleurs le maître qui ne pouvait
prendre des photos d'avions ouais bah si
le paysage la rof darroch à un concours
de photos de râches les gars là d'un
drap couché de soleil un lever de soleil
si c'est beau ici si tu réalises la
petitesse de l'homme
deux mois qu'on est infiniment petit dre
la création du monde ici des petits
riens
tu es tellement havas tellement agréable
accor déçoit pas là et des places où on
va décharger les ours polaires faut
avoir des pétards contre les ours ou un
peu fou où il faut arrêter ben bonheur
parce qu on est avertis qu'ils avaient
des hausses dans le coin pour survivre
ici pendant au moins dix mille envers
mon choix je suis béat d'admiration
il reste en pure nature que
tranquillement en train de détruire
avant tu veux arriver à la même période
de temps puis la mère était couvert de
glace juste la glace uniforme 2 3 m et 2
m ou 1 m aujourd'hui c'est toute la
glace qui est amovible qui se promène un
peu partout c'est pas la même classe des
conditions de navigation donc sont plus
difficiles qu'avant
ceux qui pensent que le réchauffement
terrestre jobs devrait venir ici ça
paraît
[Musique]